personal finance is not a feeling it's a
math thing that's correct and so here's
a here's a feeling for you
if you don't have the money
don't buy it
see that's not a Feeling
that's a principle yes maturity and I
but I want it that's a feeling but I'm
going to throw a fit like a spoiled
three-year-old on the serial aisle
that's a child
it's a child
and I deserve it you don't deserve
anything you haven't earn the money to
pay for it come on you know don't tell
me you deserve something you don't
deserve anything shut up call the
wambulance
seriously if you if you deserved it you
could work and save up the money and pay
for it then we can say you deserve it
so people say Dave you need to quit
saying better than I deserve better than
I deserve is not a statement of
contentment that's a spiritual statement
I deserve hell and I'm not going because
of Jesus that's better than I deserve